AFFAIRS WILL COME TO ORDER.
WELCOME TO OUR VETERANS WHO ARE
WATCHING OR IN THE HOUSE AND TO
SERVE THE ARMY NAVY AIR FORCE
RECORD AND COAST GUARD LADIES
AND GENTLEMAN GOOD AFTERNOON.
IN RESPONSE THE COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC SENATORS AND THE SENATE
STAFF WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTINCT. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE WILL BE HOLDING AN
ESSENTIAL HEARING. AND HAS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE.
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS WHILE CONDUCTING THE
HEARING IN A WAY THAT PROTECTS
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THE
PUBLIC AND OUR EMPLOYEES. AS WE
COMPLY WITH THOSE ORDERS WE'RE
HOLDEN ARE COMMITTEE HEARINGS
HERE IN THE CAPITAL. WITH SOME
OF OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PARTICIPATING IN DEBATE
REMOTELY WITH THE USE OF. A
VIDEO CONFERENCE SYSTEM. FOR
MEMBERS WHO WILL BE ATTENDING
REMOTELY TODAY PLEASE MUTE YOUR
TELEPHONE FOR COMPUTERS. ARE IT
PERSONNEL WILL MUTE OR UNMUTE
THE VIDEO SERVICE. WHEN YOU
WISH TO SPEAK. THIS WILL
GREATLY EIGHT AND ELIMINATING
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. I ASK
THAT EVERY TIME THAT YOU HAVE A
COMMENT OR QUESTION YOU USE THE
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM. WHAT'S RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
AND THE BILL NUMBER TWO WHICH
YOU ARE REFERRING. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY. AND
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE DESTRUCTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE FOR. THE HAVE
THE CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE
EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARING IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIMES OR PARTICIPANT ED ANY
TECHNICAL ISSUES THAT MAY ARISE
WE FORGET THAT WE PLEASE
FORGIVE US. AND WE WILL PROCEED
TODAY. PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT SO ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES CAN BE HEARD. BEFORE WE
BEGIN LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM
I'D LIKE TO REMIND MEMBERS TO
TURN ON THE MICROPHONE WHICH-
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ARCHULETA HERE HELLO HERE HELLO
YEAH ROTH. WE HAVE A QUORUM FOR.
SECRETARY ACKNOWLEDGES THAT WE
HAVE ESTABLISHED A QUORUM. I
WOULD LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
SENATOR TOM UMBERG WHO IS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY AND
COMMENTS QUESTIONS AND DEBATE
TODAY. BUT WILL NOT BE VOTING.
WE HAVE ONE BILL ON THE
CALENDAR TODAY WHICH IS ON
CONSENT. DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. CENTER
ROTH. SO MOVE THANK YOU THE
CASSETTE CALLARD IS MOVED BY
SENATOR ROTH AGAIN AT PLEASE
TURN ON YOUR MICROPHONE SO
EVERYONE CAN HEAR YOUR VOTE.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DO YOU PASS BUT
FIRST REFER TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS WITH
RECOMMENDATION TO CONSENT
ARCHULETA. FIVE LETTER I GROWTH
I WROTE I WOULD BATTLE I
WITHOUT A AYE ROTH HI ROB I.
BILLS OUT FOUR ZERO SIR. THANK
YOU SO MUCH EMISSIONS AND
MOTION WAS BEEN CARRIED. AND
BLAZING GERMAN I'D LIKE TO
THANK YOU ALL IN A SPECIALLY
LIKE TO THANK THE STAFF WOULD
PUT THIS HEARING TOGETHER TO
EVERYONE WHO SUBMITTED THEIR
SUPPORT. PLEASE SUBMIT OUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE VETERANS AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE.
COMMENTS SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO ALL OF US AND WE
WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY
IN THE OFFICIAL HEARINGS AND
RECORDS. THANK YOU EVERYONE FOR
YOUR PATIENCE AND COOPERATION
WE HAVE CONCLUDED THE AGENDA.
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
VETERANS AFFAIRS IS NOW
ADJOURNED. THANK YOU.